hey guys it's max today we're going to
be comparing the brand new galaxy buds
live against the galaxy buds plus i'm a
huge fan of galaxy but samsung has been
doing a great job
and in our comparison to the airpods pro
a ton of you guys
didn't really want to know about this
you guys want to know how these compare
so that's exactly what we're doing today
we're not only going to look at the
sound quality
the microphone quality with the latest
updates i just updated these
but also talk about everything else
including price and which one
you should buy before we start i almost
forgot to take this mask off
uh actually it's there for a purpose i
know you guys are loving this mask a ton
of you guys are ordering you guys are
ordering more than one and coming back
super comfortable go check out our merch
shelf down below or pick up one of these
really comfortable
premium maxtec tees let's start off with
the cases
themselves the new galaxy buzz live uses
squarish design
so it's a little bit larger this way a
little bit deeper i guess but not only
that it's
also a little bit thicker as well and in
my bigger pockets it's hard to tell the
difference but if you have
tighter jeans or shorts with smaller
pockets the galaxy buds plus case is
definitely a little bit more comfortable
both cases use usb type-c to charge and
you also have wireless charging built in
which is really nice
now as far as the battery life things
get a little bit interesting if we take
a look at total run time
the galaxy buds plus get 22 hours
compared to
28 hours with the lives if you don't use
active noise cancellation and we'll talk
about that in a bit it's going to get
very interesting now the actual buds
themselves
the galaxy buds live will get eight
hours without that noise cancellation
compared to
11 on the galaxy buds plus 11 is a huge
number but i think there's a little bit
of trickery going on there see
when you're using these connected to
your phone
it actually defaults in normal mode and
in normal mode it's fairly
quiet and the sound doesn't sound
amazing it sounds like the old school
ones
but as soon as i switched it to dynamic
it sounded fantastic
it was louder but battery life was
decreased
closer to the eight to nine hour point
and of course if you're gonna allow big
speed to run
both these are gonna get cut down on
battery life and the noise cancellation
cuts it down a little bit more you guys
see the full hours right here
interestingly the buds live in the
normal mode
sound very loud and sound great just
like the plus isn't dynamic
so i don't know what they changed and
why they're doing it a little bit
differently with these new ones now both
these are ipx
2 water resistant rating so there's no
difference there but i did notice a
difference when you're putting it into
the case
the plus are much easier to get the
orientation correct
drop it in it goes in where these ones
they just kind of rest on top
they don't lock in as well and then it's
easier to get them mixed up because of
the shape
and then sometimes they won't see
correctly and i kind of have to adjust
it which it makes it a little bit less
convenient now let's talk about the
design because there's a radical
difference
you guys obviously could tell that the
live look like little beans that you put
on your ear they look quite weird
but i have to say i love it i love that
samsung tried something new they're not
using the typical design that a lot of
companies use
just this basic design which works but
it looks unique
and i enjoy it i love this you know
color they call
bronze or something but it looks just
like my gold apple watch
so i am a big fan now there's a
difference in the design that
the galaxy buds and the buds plus use a
in-ear design that is sealed off
whereas the lives they're kind of like
the original air pods where you just sit
in there
and they don't go into your ear now
let's go ahead and pop these in
you would think that this would be
really difficult to learn how to put in
but i actually got it for my very first
time i just popped it in slid it down
and it locks in and without even
adjusting a little rubber piece it stays
in there
it doesn't go anywhere and of course
with the buds plus
it's very easy as well pop it in twist
and you get a really nice seal and these
also stay in fairly well they slowly
start coming out of my ear canal
uh which i just have to push it in a
little bit but other than that they're
both pretty easy
and now let's talk about comfort with
the seal design i feel pressure
inside of my ear canal the airpod pros
kind of release that with a special
valve they have built in
but after about an hour to an hour and a
half my ear starts getting
tired whereas with the buds live so it
does depend on your ears but for me
i can wear these for about three hours
not as long as the airpod pros
but still better than the galaxy buds
plus now before i compare
noise cancellation and microphone
quality with the new software updates
let's do the exciting part and that is
sound quality
i've listened to both these extensively
but i'm going to start out with the
galaxy buds plus
which i do really like and then we'll
move over to
the lives
and now for the galaxy buds live we're
switching to these bad boys
they're louder can you tell the
difference
can you hear the other ones or no before
uh just barely
barely hear them because they're sealed
these are way louder
yeah they're way louder for me too
not only is the base deeper and richer
and more quality sounding but the highs
are more crisp as well which is what i
like about the airpod pros compared to
the galaxy butts plus
the highs are nice and sharp which i
love yeah
so i listened to a few more songs and i
have my verdict
if you want the best sound quality
definitely go for the galaxy buds
live with that angelica said that the
galaxy buds live get them if you want to
share your music
because there's a lot of sound uh
leakage i guess
whatever they call it where your people
next year are going to hear your music
if you turn it up
with that said the galaxy buds plus
don't sound
bad yes they don't sound as good in the
bass in the mids
in the highs they're also not as loud
which was one of my issues with the
pluses and the originals
whereas the lives samsung is boosting up
the volume
and that is great if you're listening to
a podcast that was recorded too quietly
or a youtube video
you have the extra head room to be able
to turn them up which is
great now let's talk about the active
noise cancellation that samsung added to
the galaxy buds live if you guys missed
our previous video
i'll just give you guys a short rundown
samsung says that this will block out i
think 97
of frequencies below 700 megahertz
and that is key so in this room when i
put these in
we have a loud ac vent right there we
always have to denoise our audio
i turn on active noise cancellation and
it is
really weird my voice i lose all the low
end
i lose some of the low end sound from
that vent but all the higher frequencies
are still there and my brain focuses
more so
on those higher frequencies so in my
experience using these since i got them
i keep it turned off all the time i
rather hear a little bit of low noises
in a natural environment
so for me this noise cancellation is
only a marketing thing
to add to make it compete with
everything else because everybody's
adding active noise cancellation and
with that
these are sealed the galaxy buds and
bloods plus instead of the lives they're
not sealed so it's harder to do noise
cancellation
and even though the pluses don't have
active noise cancellation
it has better noise cancellation because
it's passive it seals in your ear
and now i don't hear that vent
pretty much at all i barely hear it and
it's way better without active noise
cancellation
than with them on the lives and so i was
actually just mowing my lawn
and i used checked out my weed whacker
my lawn mower
the noise cancellation lives did nothing
to that at all and i wanted these
instead so if you want to block out
sounds
just get the pluses without that active
noise cancellation
now there is one positive to that if
you're somebody that wants to hear
things around you
the non-sealed design allows you to hear
pretty much
everything so if you people come up talk
to you there's something else going on
these are much better for that kind of
use
and both of them can actually funnel
sound into your ears so
the pluses have the ambient mode on here
but it sucks
i'll be honest it sounds everything
sounds electronic
robotic and i keep it off anyways it
sounds terrible
now let's get into our microphone
comparison put on your best pair of
headphones
and let's take a listen this is the
microphone quality using the new
samsung galaxy buds live which have
updated microphones and possibly better
algorithms
but we'll see what this quality sounds
like and compares when we switch over
to the buds plus and here are the older
galaxy buds plus which didn't sound very
good as far as microphone quality when
we got them
but there have been a number of software
updates the latest which i just
installed
so let me know which one sounds better
to you in the comment section
let me know down below which one sounded
better as far as microphone quality the
new galaxy buds live or the pluses
with its latest firmware update and now
let's get into the conclusion now as far
as msrps the galaxy buds live cost about
20 dollars more
but with that said right now you can get
some great deals on the pluses about 130
bucks with a warranty or even about 109
on amazon
we'll leave a link down below without
that one year warranty which makes it a
lot less expensive
with that i would just say if you just
want the best sound quality and you like
loud music go with the lives as long as
you know that they are not going to work
for your active noise cancellation
and blocking any sound in general
they're a little bit more comfortable
you can hear stuff around you
and they're a great device i personally
love how they look
but if you're okay with sacrificing a
little bit of quality you want a better
deal
these will block out noise as well they
still
sound good the battery life is great
they're good headphones overall
even for iphones or for you know if you
especially that android phone
i still think a lot of people are gonna
be buying these because they do want to
block out some of that sound if they're
doing you know mowing the lawn they're
traveling
it still works great without that
marketing you know
print on the box so let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below this
been max and i will see you in the next
[Music]
video